Anna wants to celebrate her birthday by
eating pizza with her friends P boxes of
pizza cost $40 total each box of pizza
costs $8 select all equations that
describe this situation so before I even
look at that let me at least try to
construct one in my own brain so P boxes
of pizza cost $40 each box of pizza cost
$8 so one way that I could say what
would be the total cost of pizzas in
terms of P well it's going to be the
number of boxes that I get times the
cost per box so it's going to be P times
8 or 8 P is going and the other way of
saying that 8 the total cost of my box
of my pizza is 8 P or I could say it's
$40 so 8 P must be equal to $40 and we
have that captured right here in this
first equation the number of pizza boxes
is P you multiply that times 8 because
it's $8 per box that's going to be
that's my total cost of boxes which I
also know is going to be $40 so these
two things must be equal to each other
now anything else that I select really
has to be the same thing as this first
equation just manipulated a little bit
so over here I have 40 divided by 8 is P
so there's a couple of ways to think
about it if I take the total amount that
I spend on pizza $40 and I divide by the
cost per box so if I divide by 8 that
should give me the number of boxes and
that's what this is saying take my total
cost divided by my cost per box and it
should give me the number of boxes
another way of thinking about it is if
you take both sides of this equation and
divide both sides by 8 on the left hand
side 8p divided by 8 is P and on the
right hand side 40 divided by 8 is well
40 divided by 8 and doesn't matter if we
rewrote P equals 40 divided by 8 or 40
divided by 8 is equal to P they're just
saying that both of these quantities are
equal so this is also another way to
describe a situation now let's think
about this right over here 8 divided by
40 is equal to P well this is not
consistent either with
this statement or with some of the other
things that we checked we're on the left
hand side we're taking the reciprocal
and on the right hand side we aren't so
these these two things cannot be
equivalent over here we have 40 divided
by P is equal to 8 so if I just said hey
look I spent $40 on on pizza and I
bought P boxes how much does each of
those boxes cost I would say well I
would take 40 divided by P to figure out
how much each of those boxes cost and
then they tell us that that must be
equal to 8 that each box equals 8 so
this seems consistent with what we just
read and you can algebraically
manipulate any of these top two to get
to this one right over here
right up here if you divide both sides
by P on the left hand side you have 8 P
divided by P which would be 8 and on the
right hand side 40 divided by P is just
4 u divided by P so it's the same exact
thing and the last one you have P is
equal to 8 times 40 well we already know
that P is equal to 40 divided by 8 so
it's definitely not going to be 8 times
40 so that one does not does not apply
so let's check our answer we got it
right let's do a couple more Molly and
Tori like to eat ice cream sandwiches
Molly ate 5 ice cream sandwiches and
Tori ate and ice cream sandwiches in one
week they had a total of 12 ice cream
sandwiches together select all of the
equations that accurately describe the
situation so Molly eight five Tori a 10
so 5 plus n is the total that they ate
and they tell us that that must be equal
to 12 that the total of 8 together is 12
so 5 plus 10 is 12 so we immediately see
that one right over there now anything
else that we check has to be consistent
with 5 plus n is equal to 12 or it has
to be a way to algebraically manipulate
from this to anything else that is true
so let's go one by one so as n minus 5
equal to 12 so n minus 5 is going to be
the difference between what Tori ate and
Molly ate and that's not going to be 12
their sum is 12 so we're not gonna check
that here we have 12 is equal to n minus
5 which is an equivalent statement of
this top one which we already know is
not true that all they did is swap both
sides of this equality so that's not
true 5 minus n is equal to 12 well
that's just a difference between Molly
and Tori and that's definitely not going
to be equal 12 the
of the two is going to be equal the sum
of the two is going to be equal to 12
and then finally well we know this is
right and then this right over here n
plus five and five have this equipped we
already know that five plus N is equal
to 12
what's a completely equivalent statement
to say two twelve is equal to n plus
five you're just swapping the left and
right hand sides of the equality and so
let's check our answer let's do one more
mr. Herman's class is selling candy for
a school fundraiser the class got a
total the class has a goal of raising
five hundred dollars by selling C boxes
of candy for two dollars each write an
equation that the students could solve
to figure out how many boxes of candy
they need to sell so let's think about
in terms of C how much money they would
raise so let's say they sell C boxes for
each box they get two dollars so the
total amount they're gonna get is two
times C or we can even just write to C
right over there so this is the total
amount that they're going to raise in
terms of C now we know that the goal is
to raise five hundred dollars so we want
to figure out at what C does the total
amount that they raise does that equal
five hundred so this right here is the
equation that the students could solve
to figure out how many boxes of candy
they need to sell let me check our
answer and of course to solve this we're
essentially saying two times C is equal
to five hundred so you might be able to
solve it in your head you might say two
times what is 500 and you would get 250
or if you wanted to solve it a little
bit more systematically you just divide
both sides by 2
- C divided by 2 is C 500 divided by 2
is 250 and you get c is equal to 250